today we adopted counselor conclusions
of the midterm review of the EU
biodiversity strategy which deliver
clear messages nature protection has a
big variety of co benefits such as
protection of health protection of our
climate and providing clear water for
example second issue we discussed was
the neck directive we adopted a general
approach today on the neck directive air
pollution affects the health of all our
citizens urgent action is needed to
improve the air quality in Europe the
air quality directive is a very
difficult file and progress has been
very slow over the last two years member
states were not able to compromise and
take this file a step further after
difficult discussions this morning we
think we achieved a balanced compromise
today which gets the support from many
member state and is still ambitious
today's agreement of by the environment
ministers allows us to move into
negotiations with the european
parliament and i wholeheartedly welcome
this however the general approach agreed
today does not get close enough to the
health impact reduction of fifty-two
percent that we are aiming at the fifty
two percent level is not only reasonable
but it is also achievable today the
Commission takes note of the position of
the council which should bring a first
reading agreement within reach and I am
convinced that it is possible for member
states to significantly reduce the
number of premature deaths due to air
pollution through cost-effective
measures as part of a balanced approach
that allocates efforts between member
states and also efforts between sectors
I think that the conclusions reflect the
serious concerns about biodiversity loss
a concern held by no less than
three-quarters of European citizens